enfant je suis tombé dans la musique
comme obélix par hasard est tombé dans
la marmite de potion magique
c'est par hasard que je suis rentré en
cours de solfège au conservatoire de
rabat en accompagnant ma soeur qui
prenait des cours de danse c'est aussi
par hasard qu avec mon père on a choisi
le violon qui était à l'époque l'un des
instruments de moins cher c'est toujours
par hasard que j'ai rencontré deux
professeurs merveilleux qui ont été pour
moi des parents spirituels
l'un d'entre eux à rabat mme enfermée à
double tour chez lui à la maison avant
les concours au conservatoire pour que
je n'avais pas joué au tennis ou voir
les filles l'autre à paris à son décès
m'a légué son aile de ces deux violons
et vous comprendrez à quel point ceux-ci
donc est important pour moi ce sont ces
mêmes professeurs qui m'ont insuffler la
passion de la musique qui m'ont poussé à
entrer consacré au conservatoire à paris
en même temps que nos études d'ingénieur
et nous sachant choisir entre mon métier
et ma passion j'ai décidé de rentrer au
maroc pour participer au développement
économique de mon pays mais aussi à son
développement culturel en réalisant un
rêve le rêve de créer l'orchestré
philharmonique du maroc
je ne vous raconterai pas l'écart entre
les 40 et une répétition qu'il a fallu
pour donner notre premier concert en
février 97 lits tous les grands artistes
qu'on a accompagné alors qu'est ce que
l'art monique ni le plaisir pour un père
de jouer avec sa fille sur scène ni
également toutes ces difficultés qu'on a
connus pour arriver en apothéose en
décembre 2013 à jouer la grande 9e
symphonie de beethoven
devant 4000 spectateurs à casablanca en
presque vingt ans d'expérience alors
qu'elle se fait là monique du maroc nous
avons acquis une réelle expertise dans
la formation et recruter de nombreux
musiciens
nous avons voulu mettre ce savoir faire
à la disposition de jeunes enfants
étaient scolarisés issus de quartiers
défavorisés pour leur permettre
d'acquérir un métier
le métier de musicien professionnel des
enfants dont le seul avenir est
malheureusement de ne pas en avoir
c'est comme ça que le programme média a
été créé ce n'a pas été facile
ça n'a pas été facile il a fallu gérer
tous les jours le passage d'un milieu
souvent chargés de violence et de misère
vers un milieu de la musique classique
fait par contre de travail de rigueur et
surtout de concentration pour vous dire
après quelques mois
les enfants se sont adoucis grâce à la
musique
il devenait moins agressif et il sortait
du transport scolaire de moins en moins
ensanglanté parce que ça se passe est
souvent mal au démarrage
les enfants ont une formation de quatre
heures d'instruments chaque jour
cours collectifs cours individuels mais
ils ont également une formation
élémentaire de base mathématique arabe
français pour la culture générale
j'ai pu constater une vraie métamorphose
de ses enfants en quelques mois
c'est spectaculaire à tel point que
quand nous voulons les punir
actuellement nous leur enlevant leur
leurs instruments c'est paradoxal un
petit violoniste nordine nous disait il
ya quelques mois quand j'étais petit il
a 8 ans quand j'étais petit j'étais pas
sérieux j'ai fait beaucoup de bêtises
j'avais de mauvaises fréquentations et
maintenant j'ai compris que mon seul
avenir ma dernière chance
c'est mon violon estimé ya huit ans
actuellement nous avons une quarantaine
d'enfants dans une classe pilote
d'instruments à cordes et nous espérons
d'ici trois ans en avoir 200 pour avoir
deux orchestres à rabat et à casablanca
ce que nous permettons à ces enfants
c'est un vrai avenir professionnel avec
une embauche pour les meilleurs d'entre
eux à l'orchestré philharmonique du
maroc comprendrait bien qu'on on va en
profiter un peu mais tous les autres
trouveront un métier dans la musique
pas forcément dans la musique classique
mais dans la musique en général
mais au-delà de ce métier ces enfants
auront un vrai avenir et pourront enfin
donner un sens à leur vie
je vais demander maintenant à ce qu'on
ouvre ce rideau pour qu'on les entende
ce soir si on veut bien l'ouvrir
ces enfants peuvent jouer tout seul mais
si vous le permettez je vais m'offrir un
petit plaisir et je vais peut-être jouer
avec eux au fond d'eau font de
l'orchestré de petits morceaux
spring fever et la marche triomphale de
aïda de verdi
alors qu'est-ce médailles à des jeunes
mesdames et messieurs